[Music]
you of course lost a caps natively Cory
Monteith who had been on our show many
many times and he was just really
wonderful wonderful guy person and a lot
of people are just on a human level just
wondering well how you guys how you guys
are doing now that maybe the caste is
getting obviously it's it's been a very
rough time but there's this when you
start picking up the pieces after
something as tragic as this and it's
it's funny that you say that you know
how to breach it we're picking up the
pieces now there's two things you got to
remember at Corey one is he was a really
funny guy had a great sense of humor and
he loved life and he always took care of
his friends and one of his friends to be
happy so it's only right that we you
know try and starts a smile again try
and laugh again it's something that that
he would have wanted on a personal note
you know he will be severely missed but
I'm just so happy that a guy like him
got to touch as many lives as he did
while we were all lucky enough to have
him yeah well I'm all of us are wishing
you guys the back don't it obviously it
says extremely difficult
[Applause]